une moisson de médailles aux jo pour les
sportifs yvelinois les athlètes ont
remporté au total onze médailles 3 or 3
en argent et 5 en bronze à rio symbole
de ce cru exceptionnel dans la
délégation yvelinoise le boxeur tony
yoka originaires de chanteloup les
vignes
le sportif a décroché l'or dans la
catégorie super lourd je suis très fier
de moi parce que j'ai commencé ici en
voilà tous connus chanteloup-les-vignes
parce que pas une très très très très
bonne ville j'avais vraiment eu
l'occasion de briller à la télé mais
aujourd'hui voilà de pouvoir montrer que
surtout les villes c'est pas que ça qui
a comme moi il ya deux sportifs où il ya
des gens qui essaient de s'en sortir
dans la vie aujourd'hui
en aviron pas de médaille d'or mais une
troisième place pour thomas barrau que
le sportif de 28 ans licencié au cercle
nautique de versa et décroché le bronze
avec ses coéquipiers sur le quatre sans
barreur poids léger derrière la suisse
et le danemark
ça a été une expérience globalement
satisfaisante on va pas dire le
contraire
quand on voit ce que j'ai autour du cou
aujourd'hui ça a été des jo différent de
ce que j'avais connu en même temps je
n'ai pas beaucoup d'expérience
connaissait que ceux de londres en 2012
on avait la volonté on savait que
c'était possible qu'on avait le talent
et les capacités de le faire donc très
content d'y être
médaillé de bronze également les
pistards de l'équipe de france ont
quitté rio avec un goût amer favoris des
épreuves ligne montrent un françois
pervis grégory baugé originaire de
maisons laffitte et le plaisir ou à
michael d'almeida ont échoué dans leur
quête de l'or olympique en individuel
sur la vitesse et le keirin
une déception pour le clan français 5e
une déception parce qu'on attendait
quand même mieux
moi on attendait l'événement ring nantes
en 2002 - qui rythment rang des
médailles et pourquoi pas moi aussi et
puis même si on doutait bien que la
vitesse par équipes fallait dur on
pensait quand même aller en finale 1 et
2 et finalement on fait troisième c'est
bien mais ce n'était pas suffisante dans
les sports collectifs laurisa landre
originaire de poitiers a réussi
l'exploit de décrocher une médaille
d'argent avec l'équipe de france de hand
une première historique pour le handball
féminin français j'ai parcouru parcours
en balistique
j'éprouve une grande fierté dans les
chartes et de devenir de la douche bien
je vais aussi repenser à tout ça
la parenthèse riou se referme pour les
sportifs y vinoy les athlètes ont
désormais quatre ans pour s'entraîner
afin d'améliorer les résultats obtenus
en terre carioca rendez-vous à tokyo en